bonsoir à zilina ebe merci d'être à la
mode est à ce moment qu du chef de
l'état aujourd'hui dans votre ville est
ce que c'est vraiment ce que les jeunes
notamment de votre ville attendent ce
projet de mentorat emmanuel macron
comment at il été accueilli
alors pour rien vous cacher j'ai encore
du mal à bien comprendre le plan que
propose le président et ce gouvernement
donc un jeune une solution j'ai et je ne
vous cache pas que j'ai du mal à prendre
qui se trame derrière ce nom est ce
qu'il s'agit de toucher les jeunes pour
effet à un stage de trois semaines
ou est-ce qu'il s'agit la cible elle
souhaite rentrer dans relation beaucoup
plus tôt ou de l'accès à l'emploi est
pas que j'ai voyagé un peu pas la route
alors on a la chance sur certains
d'avoir un campus de formation à
l'initiative de la fondation total
un tout petit mais qui pour moi était
déjà au csu sont largement engagée bien
avant la noce de ce plan donc voilà j'ai
franchement en avoir échangé avec
quelques jeunes de de ma ville on ne
voit pas franchement exactement que
représente ce plan j'ai un peu le
sentiment que c'est un slogan qui est
sorti du chapeau un jeune solution alors
est-ce que la solution c'est traverser
la rue pour aller chez eux
je vous cache pas que j'ai du pad un peu
à prendre g j'ai pris le temps
d'échanger avec les stocks il a pas
expliqué bah écoutez je bon
d'explication et dans le sens où le
président en personne qui l'accompagnait
en dix ans pour dépôt fait un vrai
travail lance on veut que nos relances
cris le départ comment passer mes amis
je rappelle simplement dans le départ la
seine-saint-denis en plus de vivre de
subir cette crise sanitaire of youth des
inégalités et des discriminations assez
porte en particulier en matière d'emploi
pour les jeunes
donc j'avais un peu le sentiment que les
choses étaient assez assez vague
mon but et quand je dis ça j'ai pourtant
vraiment fait l'effort décide contre un
peu qu'est-ce que derrière traitement qu
est ce que ça pouvait apporter à nos
jeunes alors je vois là j'ai évidemment
j'ai reçu le cuit le président comme le
protocole républicain le veut parce que
je suis avant tout un républicain
j'essaie de rendre un peu cette démarche
j'en ai d'ailleurs profité pour être
très franc avec vous j'en ai profité
year un moment ou à échanger avec les
stagiaires et nous sommes partis vers
une autre vie site
j'en ai profité pour lui rappeler qu pas
heureusement les jeunes aussi d'autres
alternatives que je tirais d'être
chauffeur du père ou de tenir les murs
des erreurs parce que je rappelle que
voilà je lui et j'ai très important les
distances ne pas polémiquer avec vous un
président mais vous savez ici on se
souvient de cette phrase là que j'avais
sortir durant la campagne électorale de
c'était important qu'ils comprennent que
c'est pas par le s'étirait par la
stigmatisation par le ppri qu'il faut
s'adresser aux jeunes donc là j'ai eu un
peu le sens de se redorer un peu le
blason auprès des jeunes des quartiers
populaires etc
je rappelle simplement qui s'est déplacé
à la fondation total qui est un
magnifique est donc atteint
moi j'aurais préféré que puissent venir
avaient tiré des quartiers populaires de
la ville échanger avec des jeunes et je
le sais on était le réel très bien
accueilli totalement basse mais vraiment
échanger sur des soutiens aux et sur les
grandes difficultés rencontrées les
jeunes à la fois les jeunes qui n'ont
pas de diplôme et aussi des jeunes
malheureusement le papa pourquoi pour
des réseaux nation d'inégalités on a
entendu donc ce que vous avez dit au
président est ce qu'il nous a apporté
quand même une
une réponse dans cette conversation il a
été très courtois il semblait vouloir
dire que ce que je disais le partager
voilà donc c'était assez là c'était
assez assez particulier comme en
déplacement où ils étaient à l'écouté
n'était pas forcément dans une posture
de vouloir contredire ce que je pouvais
dire etc
mais j'ai aussi énormément insisté que
derrière nous attendons des actes
concrets et que c'est pas simplement un
slogan pour qu'il faut sortir ou un plan
parce que des plans nous nous en
connaissons malheureusement des dizaines
et dizaines que nous avons pu voir et
qu'on a pu nous présenter dans nos
villes côtières
il faut derrière des actes concrets qui
semblait qui semblait manquer emmanuel
macron dit en gros le mentorat créer des
passerelles des ponts inter
générationnel entre des milieux des
territoires différents se vient de
solidarité cette connexion sont
extrêmement précieux dans les temps
actuels c'est un discours qui vous parle
vous êtes en accord ou ce sont de belles
phrases pour vous on peut être qu'on
d'accord mais le mentorat ne suffit pas
ce qu'il faut de mon point de vue qui je
le dis d'ailleurs je lui dis oh vraiment
véritable gt r est dynamique il faut
vraiment un plan de bataille pour faire
en sorte que les entreprises
s'installent dans les territoires
populaire et c'est le cas à stains
puisse ouvrir leurs portes
recruter des jeunes formés des jeunes
est allé vers de l'emploi durable c'est
pas simplement la solution ne peut pas
constituer ne peut pas être considéré
avec des emplois précaires ou justement
donner encore plus d'argent à des
entreprises qui veulent s'engager dans
dupont tintin va s'engager quand
insertion derrière il faut vraiment des
actions fortes les actions concrètes en
matière d'emploi le jeune à la fois pour
ceux qui ne sont pas diplômés mais aussi
pour ceux qui sont diplômés qui
malheureusement est donc extrêmement
compliqué
on trouve de très grosses difficultés
pour trouver un travail donc voilà vous
savez on est en attente que je
souhaitais rendre c'est un maire d'une
ville propre terre moi je suis en
attente dax et actes de concret et
malheureusement je n'ai pas très
franchement essaie de comprendre ce
ratage prendre un peu le merci beaucoup
c'est dente libye d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rtl route